let's divide 9815 by 65 or figure out
how many times the 65 go into 9815 and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own so let me just
rewrite this as 9815 divided by 65
divided by 65 and we write it this way
because it's easier to manipulate the
numbers kind of doing the standard
process here and as we'll see whenever
we divide by a number that has more than
one digit there's a little bit of an art
to it and hopefully you'll get an
appreciation for that art over the
course of this video so first we can
think about well how many times is 65 go
into nine well does it go into nine at
all so we can move one digit to the
right how many times does it go into
ninety eight without going over it well
65 times one is 65 so that doesn't go
over it and 65 times two well that would
be 130 so that would go over 198 so it
only goes one time it only goes one time
we multiply 1 times 65 which is 65 and
then we could subtract to see how much
we have left over so 8 minus 5 is 3 and
9 minus 6 is 3 and now we can bring down
we can bring down the next digit this
one here and now this is where the art
is going to come into play because we
need to figure out how many times is 65
go into 331 without going over it and it
you might just try to look at these
numbers try to approximate them a little
bit you might say well maybe 65 well let
me round this thing up maybe this is
close to 70 and let's see this is close
to this is close to 300 so maybe we say
well 70 would go into 300 so maybe we
think about how many times does 70 go in
to 300 and we say without going over it
it doesn't go exactly into 300 well well
you could say well how many times does 7
go into 30 well we know 7 goes into 30 4
times 4 times 7 is 28 so maybe try a 4
right over here because then this will
be 284 times 70 is 280 you're still
going to have a little bit left over but
what you have left over
going to be less than 70 it's going to
be 20 so you say well if this is roughly
70 and if this is roughly 300 then maybe
it's going to be the same thing so let's
try that out let's see if it goes four
times so four times five is 20 carry the
2 4 times 6 is 24 plus 2 is 26 and now
let's see how much we had left over so
when we subtract when you subtract we
are left with this in a new color 1
minus 0 is 1 we have a 3 here and a 6
here so we have to do a little
regrouping let's take 100 from the
hundreds place becomes 200 give those 10
tens that hundred to the tens place so
now we have 13 tens 13 minus 6 is 7 and
then 2 minus 2 is 1 so did this work out
well no our remainder after we said it
went in four times we actually had 71
left over 71 this right over here is
larger than 65 you don't want a
situation where what you have left over
is larger than what you were trying to
divide into the number you could have
gone into it one more time and and
because you had so much left over so
this 4 was actually too low we should
have probably approximated this is 60
and 60 goes into 300 if we were to
estimate we'd say well that might be
closer to 5 times so this is where the
art of this comes into play so it was
very reasonable to do what I just did
but it just turned out to not be the
right way to think about it I could just
say oh well 4 wasn't enough I had too
much left over let me try 5 now 5 times
5 is 25 carry the 2 5 times 6 is 30 plus
2 is 32 there you go we got much closer
331 without going over now we can now we
can subtract and once again we could do
a little regrouping take 10 from the
tens place this becomes 2 tens this
becomes an 11 11 minus 5 is 6 2 minus 2
is 0 3 minus 3 is 0 so we only have 6
left over which is obviously less than
65 so we're all good and if we if we put
a 6 here and we would have gone over 3
31 and so that wouldn't have been cool
either but anyway let's bring down the
next digit let's bring down the five so
how many times is sixty five go into
sixty-five well it goes one time one
times 65 and okay ignore this is from a
previous step one times 65 is 65 and
then you subtract and we have no
remainder no remainder so we see that
sixty five goes into 9815 exactly
exactly 150 let me describe that in that
same blue color
one hundred and I don't want to do all
these arbitrary colors 151 times 151
times